how is everyone doing having a good kiss
under day so my name is Evan and I'm
here to talk to you about spark and
Cassandra so I'm a staff engineer at we
Allah and been working on Apache
Cassandra and spark for well Cassandra
for a number of years and here to talk
about this really interesting fusion of
two two technologies so we will tell you
a little bit about how we use Cassandra
at ariela and how we are integrating
Cassandra and sparking a little bit
about how you can use spark with
Cassandra so who are we this is a really
brief introduction we are go with the
power personalized video experiences
across all screens that means in a
pipeful unless stated you are watching
video on one of our customer sites like
ESPN and whenever you watch a video
we're getting events we're about a seven
year old company and since the very
beginning we've been very focused on
analytic so as of today we get maybe two
and a half billion analytics pings a day
so that from our customers customers and
our customers has you know pretty big
list of some some of the top names
whenever you watch the video under sites
we are getting data and we're trying to
help them figure out like who's watching
video and how are they watching it so
that they can improve everyone's
experiences with video we are fairly
large Cassandra user we have a whole
bunch a lot of clusters ranging from the
very small a few notes to over a hundred
notes and it pretty much powers all of
our analytics infrastructure from simple
aggregates to more advanced things like
machine learning
clustering trend trend detection this
kind of thing and we're running a range
of versions from 10 or editor DSE
versions of the 102 122 we are hoping to
do at some point we eventually try out
the newer versions like 20 to that one
and we are also starting to become a big
smart user we have multiple teams using
spark and it seems that especially
recently spark has gone a huge amount of
momentum it is now a top-level paci
project this quick show of hands like
how many people have heard of a spark so
fair okay so pretty pretty well known
and how many people are actually using
it in their internet other companies
okay so so fairly small okay so so I
think this is about the right level of
talk we'll we'll go a little bit into
what spark is and hope you guys see the
use case for for using sparkles
Cassandra so what so what problem are we
trying to solve them and this is this
applies not just to us but to most
people I imagine is that we get a lot of
data right this is I mean it's not quite
that bad right but the general raw data
is pretty useless in the sense that you
know you have a lot of it but you don't
quite know how to deal with it you can't
quite present it to the your customers
right so we want to go from mountains
we're all data to to these nuggets that
you can present and you want to do this
quickly and painlessly as easy as
possible and you want to do it at scale
and no doubt you guys are here because
of Apache Cassandra because under helps
what whole bunch of these things with
the quickly in that scale but let's dive
into the problem space a little bit
further
so what we have before using spark is
that we have pre computed aggregates so
for us our data is defined along several
dimensions for example geo such as
country city device type things that you
get from the user agents and was browser
this kind of thing so what we did was
that we would precompute and in
Cassandra this is some of you guys have
probably been over at the other talk
with data modeling and cassandra is very
popular to denormalize your data so if
we had data that could be sliced nine
different ways we're just going to
compute it nine different ways and store
it you know storage is cheap and and
what what you get with that is that you
get very fast lookups so for any one of
those nine breakdowns we can get very
fast lookups we read the data back right
away and everyone's happening right the
problem with this is that though that it
is so it's a little bit inflexible right
so inflexible in terms of the way you
curry it they'll also for us it was a
bit hard to change so if we add if we
needed to do a new kind of query that
meant that you had to add a new column
family and you to change your entire
right pipeline to write things in your
way right the other problem is that it's
hard to know like you need to break down
things a lot of different ways but in
fact most of the data that's written
never gets read because it turns out
that people care about certain queries a
lot more than others right and what
happens if we need to do more dynamic
queries for example I one of the
dimensions is geo for example cities
another one might be the type of device
you are using such as mobile versus
tablet whatever wanted more complex
queries such as I wanted to cross I want
to find out the top mobile users in
France or something like that so that
involves a cross part
now if i had to materialise all the
different variations that people could
want that this would be like very it
would be really really hard to do oh and
you with this run out of space right and
there might be more interesting kind of
queries that you want to query so the
big question is you want to use concern
for a scale but how can you serve more
complex queries quickly right so you can
imagine that there's kind of a there's a
continuum on one side of the continuum
let's see this is actually oh cool okay
so on one side of the continuum is let's
say I've we compute everything which is
what I was just describing you get fast
lookups but it's pretty inflexible on
the other hand you can imagine totally
other end of the spectrum is that my
data my competition is dynamic in other
words imagine that if I always like
random every ducharme to get the restart
at one so I have a lot of flexibility
but it is really slow so that's not
going to work if you want to and you
know answer queries like interactively
right and I think what we really want is
we want something in the middle that is
partly dynamic and where you can have
enough pre aggregation but it's also but
it's also flexible and fast at the same
time so now why spark so a really quick
introduction for folks that are not
aware spark is an in-memory distributed
computing framework it actually does
support spilling over results to disk so
it's not strictly in memory it's created
by came out of the UC Berkeley and blab
about 34 years ago and initially
targeted problems that mr was really bad
at so just iterative algorithms where
you need to keep spinning on the same
data set again and again and data mining
it is more general purpose than then who
do in that it's being applied to all
sorts of problems and right now it is
getting a huge amount
momentum it is just graduated the Apache
Incubator so it's now a top-level
project projects it's getting a lot of
contributions like the rate of change in
the project this is actually like
accelerating right now so yeah a lot of
interest and just a really quick recap
of the difference in model between spark
and Hadoop in Hadoop we start out with
data and ex gfs and what you do is
everything is broken out into MapReduce
faces so we read data out of HDFS does
some map on it then you do a shuffle and
after you reduce the data then you write
back to HDFS now most jobs don't take
more than just one stage so you end up
having multiple stages which is reading
data out writing it back reading data
out waiting it back right so that that's
how that's how it works spark is a
little bit different the first
difference is that in spark you have
higher level operators than just map and
reduce so let's just leave a join
operator for example and spark with the
data transforms it it might be able to
might join all this data this is all
happening in memory and then the magic
is that instead of having to write it
back to HDFS you can write it back to a
traverse if you want but you also have
the option to cache the intermediate
result set in memory then once this is
done you could then do more
transformations and this is read out of
memory add 10 to 100 x SP de compared to
do and what we find is that throughput
and the in-memory is really a huge
benefit so I have three use cases here
one is reading out data out of Cassandra
when the caches code another is this
report i get when i read out of a warm
cash now warming a cash does make a huge
difference photo as most of you know
cash it's really hard to control like
some of the dl to come in and do
somewhere to read it and your cash is
kind of thrown out of whack right when I
cash stuff in spark I get about a
10 to 50 x speed up depending on you
know cash and other kinds of things we
find that our developers really like
spark they're able to get the API really
quickly because it's based on data high
level data transformations and it's
compared to dupe the API is much cleaner
and you have an interactive shell oops
you have an interactive shell that
allows you to experiment where quickly
this is a fun slide I like showing this
on the right side is the the Java
MapReduce program for a word count I to
shrink this to about four point font to
get it to fit on a slide on the left is
it's the same thing done in spark it is
four lines basically so it's pretty
pretty amazing one thing that is one
thing that is cool about spark is that
people have been building components on
top so for example one component that's
been built on top is called that's just
coming out is called Quebec's it is a
graph computation library kind of like
RAF lab or other things like that other
things that people have done shark is a
project for high bun spark you can run
your SQL SQL queries and finally there's
something called spark streaming which
is basically you can think of it it's
like storm at spark you can basically it
does like a tiny commutations and people
are using this for a stream processing
like second with say second latency is
that kind of thing and what is really
neat is that you can build all this
stuff on one platform so instead of
having to manage there's to do but under
storm and inter scrap lab and then
there's like under whatever else you use
right you have one platform that is you
only have to learn to maintain it once
and every time that the base platform
improves it improves the performance of
all these different modules
and the other thing that is really cool
is that you've got really good
integration so it's possible in spark
for example to run an SQL or hive QR
query writer and you can take the
results of that and you can massage it
and scala java feed it into graph la
graphics or the machine learning library
and it do like modeling on it so so this
kind of integration in spark is it's
easier it's much easier because
everything is based on the same kind of
platform and there's also integration
with mace O's and yarn in terms of
resource management I'm not going to
spend much time on this but for those of
you guys that use hi how many people
here use hive so fair bit shark is like
a hundred percent hive ql like
compatible layer the reason why is
compatible is because it actually
includes a fork of high and so we can
reuse hive udfs 30s and that kind of
thing and if you're using DSE it can
actually use just like DSE has high on
Cassandra you can also use shark on
Cassandra using Cassandra as a as a
better store which is pretty interesting
so spark looking pretty good how do you
integrate it with Cassandra so what we
do for a lot of use cases is that we
co-locate cassandra and spark so you
start off Cassandra at the bottom we add
this is optional but you can add some
logic for you know you can have young
input format or 30 that kind of thing
then we layer spark on top spark toxin
in formatted to read from Cassandra
shark because its hive base has an
additional layer that translates the
data into a corner representation which
is called a 30 in hive speak
on how that you have a this looks like
single master but in fact like a spark
actually has multi master fill over a
patient zookeeper as well as if you use
maces or yarn that those things are
taken care for you and finally we have a
rest job server that serves jobs so
different options for reading from
Cassandra first of all smart can take
any type input format and there's a
couple of that can read from Cassandra
you guys might all be aware of the base
comp there's a column family input
format which is really old it is
basically it reads all the roles from
one column family which is ok but not as
helpful for most people there is the cql
paging input format for Cassandra one or
two and up which is great it allows you
to use your secondary indexes and gives
you a lot more flexibility gives the
automatic paging you can roll your own
we actually wrote all in perform at
because we have data that spread we had
data that spread across multiple column
families and so we could do joins at REE
time as well as we're only indexes so it
we have support for that in addition
spark has a native API I'll go into what
an RDD is in a second but basically I
can very easily like I can bypass the
whole and perform at and read directly
from spark I'll go into this in just a
second finally there is the co NHO
cassandra has a native jdbc driver now
and there is someone did write some
integration with jdbc so you can you
could go through that route as well and
I think I left this thing I left this
off but
there's also some third-party
integrations there's a company in India
called to poor chump that wrote a
cassandra and spark integration which
looks very slick I yea sorry i'll add
this back to my slides at some point it
must have accidentally tooken it out if
you're using the column family input
format it will it translates it directly
basically every role in Cassandra gets
slammed into one record in spark so it's
pretty straightforward and thence Marcus
operators for operating and then you can
take each roll data and manipulated and
spark using your join and your other
operators but like I said it's not a
particularly flexible option I'm going
to go into what and rtd is in spark a
little bit because I just want to make
sure you guys are familiar with the
terminology so an RDD sense for a
brazilian distributed data set so this
is sparks basic it's marks place a
concept that you have data that is
distributed and you can manipulate it
like a a collection of data so basically
all datasets RTD so these are divided
into partitions so you can think of a
partition is a partition has to live on
one node so if you were to divide your
data / 10 notes that you would have at
least 10 predictions you could have a
lot more than 10 partitions and yeah
different partitions live on different
nodes in general you don't have to worry
about partitions too much other than as
a sizing kind of thing in general wet
and smart you're working with individual
records so these partitions would have I
don't know say you know let's say that
you have a user database and so each
user is a person so usually you're
working on the user level you're kind of
doing filters on users but sometimes it
is helpful to know the topology
underneath
so I just had a quick slide about if you
were to choose between reading about
data using and if perform at verses and
writing using sparks api's directly so I
guess the idea is that one of Cassandras
built-in in performance work for you
like the c ql paging in perform at that
works and that's the easiest route but
if you had to develop any perform at
versus doing it natively in spark we
just want to throw up some corners for
comparison and if the format is really
flexible because you could use it in
Hadoop as well as spark on the other
hand I don't know if anyone's tried
implementing an input format it's it's
kind of a big pain there's like multiple
Hadoop api's and they're very clunky
it's not the easiest thing to do so
personally like the lesson that we've
learned is that if we have to go back
and do it again we would probably have
this gone straight we would have skipped
the input format route and just done it
entirely in spark it would be much
easier Department probably saves us
about release a month maybe more the
only big disadvantage is that you can't
use you can only use that in spark
so how would I actually read data from
Cassandra like into into spark directly
using spark api's so this is how this is
in fact how we do some of our reading
you can treat a list of rockies as a
distributed data set and spark and
there's multiple ways of creating that
list but maybe you start off with an
index and your index gives you a set of
rookies so then what you do is that you
have a distributor set of rookies now
I'm going to do something called a flat
map so if flat map takes basically one
item like a rocky and it transforms it
into one or more items and then all
those results get become one big data
set so what i'm doing here is that I'm
doing we let's say you have a function
called three columns basically this
takes a row key or in NC coil three it
would be like your primary key or
whatever and then you can read in all
the data from from new row and then now
you have a distributed data set that has
all the data from those girls the reason
why i'd like to think in terms of Rho
keys is because we know that rose are
distributed across the cluster in
Cassandra so if you think of it this way
this maps pretty well to Cassandra slay
out because different role keys will go
to different nodes so this this is this
is a parallel operation you can even do
if you want to be very aggressive about
this you can even try to like figure out
what which will keys are in which
replicas and therefore try to get a note
local read to further optimize this
although depending on your usage
scenario like for us most of our
Cassandra clusters are in our own data
center so network isn't really a I mean
isn't really a big factor so it's not
something that we thought we really
needed to optimize
so our Cassandra SPARC architecture so
what we do is that as these events video
events are coming in they get let's say
to get written to wall logs somewhere
let's say they are HDFS so we process
the raw logs and we write semi
aggregated OLAP like tables into
Cassandra as collinar storage now go
into like what kind of schema we use for
this then what we do is that we load
data from Cassandra into memory and
spark or we can do very fast queries and
we can query it directly using spark for
certain predefined queries we can create
using shark for more ad hoc queries this
one to like explain a little bit why
it's not enough just to read and write
directly from Cassandra so what we have
is that every day we have about 30
million multi-dimensional fact table
rows and so these are imagine that you
have every combination possible of your
different dimensions your geo and your
other things about a user and there are
about 30 million different combinations
now for you to answer a query
materializing every possible answer
isn't really possible because for us the
user can group by multiple dimensions at
the same time let's say that you want to
group by country as well as you know
browser or something like that which is
not uncommon or more common it's like I
want to group by video watch and
something else like country so so you
end up having a lot of cross processing
and the number of combinations that are
possible from like grouping all these
different dimensions as well as
filtering and indexing it's like into
many billions so it is this not possible
to materialize that many answers in
Cassandra um so for that reason we we
take a different approach the other well
so the other approach besides trying to
materialize every answer is that you
could store your fact tables in
Cassandra this is possible let's say
that I stored I have 30 million rows in
Cassandra or I could learn million
columns or something like that that's
possible to the reason why that doesn't
really work either it's because
depending on the type of query you're
reading from basically every for every
query reading from random subset of
these 30 million rows so you're talking
about a a read that is extremely random
in nature I think with SSDs it might be
fast enough but at that scale it becomes
and this is for one day when you start
going beyond like three million like and
you're reading random data it becomes
like not I mean you can do it but it
will take a long time in Cassandra so
and c ql doesn't support some of the
higher level constructs like doing
aggregations doing grouping this kind of
thing although that's kind of a
secondary issue so our approach is we
use Cassandra store the raw fact tables
and then we optimize the schema for OLAP
workloads meaning for for very high
throughput and for and we can read over
a subset of tables and then we use spark
to do the fast in memory kind of
aggregation so this is what our skimmer
looks like we have one color family for
indexing all of the different OLAP
tables we have a metadata family that
essentially stores these are the type of
columns that we have and what what types
of columns they are they are are they
integers or a
whatever and our main color parameter
stores data this basically we store one
row per column of data and the reason
why we do that is so that we can
selectively load columns so if someone
is running a bit query most of the time
they don't need every column we only
load the columns that are needed so that
we can minimize tile the other thing
that we do is why we store things by
column is so that you can get very good
compression so you can use a lot of
techniques such as dictionary
compression other things most most
columns have a much lower cardinality of
values compared to the number of roles
that you have so we're able to achieve
very good compression using techniques
like that and we store whole bunch of
roles together that we can read them in
big chunks in it it's very fast
once we have it in memory what do we do
is that we pass queries off to our we
have a rest job server and basically
data it's basically stored loaded from
Cassandra into sparks heap space and
then we run fast query jobs that we run
off of this memory and return answers to
to the user okay right i guess i could
good through this quickly this is going
to go over really quickly like how this
works in spark basically you have
records that are distributed across
multiple nodes and in each partition
your multiple records and then you can
you can convert all these records into a
let's say a sharp table and run SQL over
it or you can for for known prairies you
can basically use whole bunch of
operators like basic map store group
join other things like that there's also
a top k operator so from that point
onward we relying mostly on spark to do
the distributed data processing just a
really quick note on fault tolerance
there is so if this data leaves the lips
in the heap you might ask well what
happens if it goes down so a spark has a
traditional fault tolerance mechanism
called lineage and what lineage says is
that I'm going to remember the exact
sequence of operations hope to compute
this and so something fails what spark
is trying to do is to we appealed stuff
in this case you don't necessarily want
to go that route because a reading stuff
rosanna might be slow so instead one
well there's different ways so one way
you can take advantage of is that spark
and replicate the memory data set across
different notes so then that way that
survives anyone
failure we're also not terribly worried
about losing data because in the worst
case we can always veto back from
Cassandra and our schemas optimized for
faster or put so it's it's not so that
hasn't been so having cassano de reserve
is a pretty big relief I guess cool I
think I don't really have time for demo
I was going to show really quickly like
how you create tables and read it from
spark but I think that's probably all
the time we have so thank you very much
oh and guess we are hiring so